yeah hit a one-time welcome to this
video at the game request i wouldn't
even i did not even have the video
software the recording so i started but
my opponent seems to be even less
prepared smita aid
hmm Oh is he somehow stunt by one year
for doctor again he had he found if I
finally okay so what do we get played
this a bit recently and this is not a
bad line em that's not bad hmm I don't
know I can take but what happens after
he won
yeah if i take the screen d forward hmm
this looks is that really good for black
I mean good in the sense of equal yeah
they give me five I don't know it looks
a tad dangerous or black maybe he's just
consolidating it's possible i mean i'm
having some kind of pin you on the
default as well Knight f6 Bishop e7 or
something but Knight f6 this one okay i
also have night at five now just
attacking the pawn but okay this cannot
possibly be bad for why does that don't
think this is possible night if a life
doesn't work and i had my queen hangs
yeah just this I guess but that's not
that bad for black 96 maybe is a little
bit too too lame it's not again it's not
terrible maybe some night g6 check okay
so I have a slightly more comfortable
ending f1 is definitely necessary here
to make the night look a little bit
stupid so she can't take it f
yeah but this is again that's slightly
more comfortable for me 94 next so would
it see it just rock d tool yeah I guess
due to the construction it's so more
comfortable for me not sure if this is
anything substantial should have gone to
e3 immediately okay not a big deal
yeah I will march the kingside soonish
so G form
you
and see I'm not quite sure if I just
want to go out a 5 here or not really
know maybe h5 here first f 595 is a bit
worrisome
night h55 it's my idea that be 684 see
going for that even the immediate f5 is
kind of interesting f5 takes f6 takes h6
would work in that would work I'm
threatening have six now
so and he just went back then if i play
f6 now he takes it g6 time morning kinky
sex okay take on age six might my twins
it might win but this is this is I think
easy him check hmm and Knight takes
Knight f6 he actually attacks each five
that's not great hmm I did not want to
take with a king originally really
didn't want to do that shoot
wanted to make sure that King you for
doesn't happen
the h-bond should do the trick now check
didn't even see that more black forfeits
on time okay so pretty technical game ya
hear this Bishop e6 is an interesting
line I know that the capture is one
possible at any takes this somehow takes
that this is kind of okay for black yeah
he gets an idea of six Bishop p6 it's
kind of okay this is weak but he's got
active pieces I tried this and probably
probably f6 isn't great I don't know
this feels very dangerous to me this is
give it by the engine that looks also
quite dangerous okay but what happened
in the game yeah this is a check still
holding for black yeah 96 was the check
very technical approach but I'm
definitely better i'm not sure how much
but my pawns are more check dangerous
enter no it's it's not easy for black to
play the computer still think it's
roughly equal bit surprised i was
thinking that this should be really good
for white
yeah only hear the engine gives why the
great advantage another great advantage
it done it's like 0.6 now yeah but here
this is this should be close to winning
a 5 now is winning for white yeah he
cannot do this as f 6 is promoting here
also f six wins I wasn't completely sure
about herbs about this position but ok
once you looky look at it yo you kind of
wonder why wasn't what was the thing
yeah and such a joke and white is
completely winning I assembly forgot
that I can still attack those pawns
there all week ok so this one is dead
but then also wins I was a little bit
more concerned about this move but I
thought I can sacrifice it and the
engineer easy I this is the move and T
I'm winning he cannot stop them both ok
so I was right about that him check it's
a technically winning ending and this is
the easiest by the way this what I did
here just keep the king I would you can
you can do that you know but I don't
know it also wins but this is easiest
just keep the King out and only only now
get it get the point if he moves the
king now can you can grab everything
here and win very easily ok guys thanks
for watching